well this really sucks so yeah you can
tell by the thumbnail I got a copyright
strike this really blows it is going to
be totally unscripted so you're going to
hear a lot of amount of size and lot of
random points of blank notes where I
just don't say anything so please
forgive that but this is really bad for
any of you that don't know what a
copyright strike is basically YouTube or
a claimant this being in this case
Ubisoft will copyright a video if they
believe that it falls under their like
guidelines of like copyrighted material
my instance it did the video intake was
the highlight the Highlander move subbed
I got leaked on reddit a couple days ago
and I thought hey I thought to be a good
idea to make into a video give it to all
you guys should the info and that's
where I [ __ ] up because I read it
Ubisoft little support page obviously
after I got this strike me being a
dumbass and it says they are not allowed
to talk about or week something about
leaking or not taking or it's either it
has something to do with leaking or not
talking about game assets before the
release so for example the Highlander
moves out is not supposed to have
actually introduced until you know
Tuesday or Saturday obviously it should
be Saturday because that's when they're
going to be talked about doing the hero
series tournament but I'm not supposed
to talk about it until they do basically
and my dumb ass didn't realize that
because I'm new to YouTube and I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] so yeah I don't exactly
remember what happens when you don't get
a strike or when you get a strike I
believe it's because I believe you can't
livestream somebody told me you can
livestream really help us out the case
because just a week ago I said that I
was going to livestream for you guys a
lot of you were all hyped about it and
it kind of shattered your [ __ ] dreams
so hopefully this all gets resolved I
did contact the Ubisoft account that did
tell me about this it's their their
email their video rights Ubisoft like
team I did email them asking if they
could retract it
I apologized and hopefully they'll get
back to me but anyway you're probably
not going to be receiving any more said
taught anything talking about leaks
anymore like I'm probably just going to
lay low so any if like the gladiator
moveset gets leaked or some [ __ ] before
it comes out which I don't know when but
first of its supposed to I believe it's
supposed to be talked about on Saturday
which is nice but anything about like
leaked heroes or something I might just
lay low on it I don't want to take this
chance again and then have me get [ __ ]
over and get two strikes so imma lay low
for a bit on that obviously still
covering the news and all that other
stuff but anything regarding leaks I'm
gonna just chill out with I'd rather be
safe than sorry and not get [ __ ] over
anyway
sighs a super late video it's like 10:30
when I'm making this so some of you are
probably asleep some of you probably
never sleep be the way I'm sorry for
that guys it's my bad but I just want to
say thank you to all the new subs from
that video though I did that video did
extremely well they got like 28,000
30,000 views in like a day so I'm super
happy about that though it does suck
that the videos gone I did gain about
like 250 subs just from around those
videos so shut all told that all the new
subs I'm sorry that you had to get
introduced and get a copyright strike on
the video that you sub to me for sorry
about that and shout out all you og subs
doing that that's still been with me you
guys are the best - anyway I'll probably
do probably a video on Saturday when
they talk anything to talk about
in the hero Series tournament I'll be
covering and if anything is kind of
sketchy to me like if there's a week or
something don't expect me to cover it I
just want to stay safe for a bit guys
anyway thank y'all for the support
really do enjoying it though guys I've
1952 subs as I'm making this so we're
about 48 subs away from making 2000 so
once again super grateful for you guys
shout out to all you
anyway I'll see you in probably
tomorrow's video guys peace out